He was a force of nature,
the quintessential Aussie outdoorsman with this wicked sense of humor and his
insatiable passion for wildlife.
Steve Irwin,
the crocodile hunter,
became a worldwide celebrity.
He shone a spotlight on man's mismanagement of our natural resources and
champions.
The plays of the planet's most vulnerable inhabitants,
the animals,
but Steve was also a dare devil,
constantly pushing the limits in his interactions with the wiles.
Then in a tragic moments,
he was gone,
taken from us far too soon.
In today's biographics,
we get to grips with the crocodile hunter from down under
Steven Robertson.
When was born on February the 22nd 1962 in Melbourne,
Australia.
Both of his parents were passionate about wildlife is father Bob was a plumber,
but he was also a keen hepatologist who studied amphibians while his mother Lynn
was a wildlife rehabilitator.
When Steve was just a few years old,
the family moved to Queensland's where Bob and Lynn opens the Queensland Reptile
and Foreigner Park.
Steve therefore grew up around his reps and was and we're soon put to work at
the park.
He would clean out the cages and feed the crocodiles and the lizards.
By the age of six,
he was accustomed to being around creatures that most children would be
terrified of.
His whole existence was surrounded by wildlife from crocodiles to Kangaroos to
wireless.
The Iowans develops their reptile park from nothing.
They spend the first couple of years living in a caravan while they slowly added
to that animal inventory.
The first snakes they put on display where ones the Bob and Steve captured while
out fishing.
Meanwhile then was busy rehabilitating orphans,
Joey's Kangaroos,
Koalas,
wombats,
snakes,
and craze.
At the same time,
she was raising three children of her own Steve proof to be a mischievous child
who was always testing the patients of his father.
He would constantly go missing,
only to be discovered down at the local creek or chasing visits.
Yet he wasn't being rebellious.
He wanted to find venomous snakes and lizards so the team could show them to his
dad and to win his approval,
but rather than making him proud,
Steve's constant wanderings left.
Bob Frustrated there.
Boy was hyperactive.
He never sat still from the age of two.
He developed a skill and to love for climbing trees.
So the first thing that his family members would do when he went missing was
look up on the way to school.
If he saw a dead reptile lying on the road,
Steve would make his mother stylists so that he could get out and investigate.
When he was six years old,
he got the best present.
He could have wished for a 12 foot long python.
Steve Absolutely adored his new best friend at school.
Steve was considered a bit of an oddity by his peers.
He wasn't into the normal boy things like bicycle sports and skateboards.
He spends his lunchtimes wandering around the school yards and looking for
birds,
lizards,
and any other creatures that he could find.
After a while,
other kids got involved looking to Steve as the local experts on all things
related to wildlife.
Baba when was a hero and a mentor to his son.
He was a wildlife innovator who was at the cutting edge of animal husbandry with
the wildlife park established the good supply of smaller reptiles and animals.
What would the sizes?
It was time to add a couple of crocodiles.
It took nine year old Steve with him on his first crocodile humps as expected,
the boy was extremely active and it was all his dad could do to keep them in the
boat.
When a crock was cited,
Steve would want to be the first one to grab it.
He was positioned at the front of the boat with a spotlight while his father was
operating the outboard motor.
As they got close,
Steve fixed desires and what he thought was a small CROC.
Then he bounced out of the boat and it's got into the water grabbing us by the
neck,
but the boy he didn't realize how launched this crocodile was.
It was in fact about the same size as him,
quite a bit stronger.
When it became clear to Bob that his son was getting the worst of the encounter,
he reached his arm into the water and scoops up both of them scooping the boy
hams,
the Croc into the boat and pinning the animal down with his body recovering
quickly.
Steve took over the job of holding down the crock with a huge smile on his face.
It was one of the proudest moments of his life so far.
In the early seventies reports of crocodiles attacking people were becoming more
and more frequent around Australia.
As the stock of crocodiles at the reptile park grew,
Bob decided to involve himself in attempts to resolve the conflicts between
crocodiles and humans.
He joins the East Coast Crocodile and management program and he and Steve threw
themselves into the task of capturing and relocating crocs from areas where
there was potential for an osteon counter with humans.
It was extremely dangerous work,
but it was exciting and young.
Steve Excels is this,
here's a natural gift for not only locating the crocs,
but also for capturing them.
He would get absolutely focused on catching a crocodile as if you were entering
into one on one combat with us.
Once the CROC was secured and subdued in his nest,
he would get a huge adrenaline rush,
which would make him keen for the next encounter,
but at the time he was in his late teens.
Steve was living in the Bush for extended periods of time,
camping out under the stars and spending days at a time in pursuit of a single
KROC.
He had to live off the land and the water,
honing his Bush skills while developing the mystique of the crocodile hunter.
It was grueling work and most of the time Steve was on his own.
He was young,
he was fit.
He was keen and he was innovative.
Steve became the most successful crocodile hunter in the land with his grand
reputation,
came a degree of complacency.
Though he begins to feel that he could do anything.
On one occasion,
he got a crock back to his camp,
ready to put it in a crate,
but he neglected to secure the animal's mouth,
not realizing this.
Steve let the Croc out of its nest as he prepared the Christ.
Then with his back turned the crock attacked,
snapping.
It's huge jaws around his neck.
Fortunately,
Steve Gone out of this situation with nothing but a few holes in his boot.
On another occasion,
Bob Winds up into northern Queensland in search of an infamous crock known as
agro.
This creature would pop.
Its head is out of the water right next to the boats.
Horrifying the locals.
Bob's goal was to locate the beast and set up a marker so that his son could
follow up and execute the capture.
Bob located the CROC easily and has made a mark and then overhanging tree so
that Steve would know where to set the trap.
Yes.
From the moments that he went in,
Steve could feel that agro was stalking him as he was setting the trap or
something bumped into his boat and his dog again barking.
Steve quickly set the trap and then left.
Now he was simply a matter of watching and waiting.
On the third day,
Steve headed for the site.
You need to discover that the trap was completely submerged under water.
The base had been taken and the trap and gone off.
Steve brought his boat close and grabbed a hold of the net's ready to drag the
capture of crock on deck.
Suddenly there was a massive upheaval as the crocs smashed into the boat from
under the water.
A stun.
Steve managed to maintain his grip on the nest,
but then another blow rock to the boat and then another,
but Steve,
he held on Mandy.
He began dragging the net in.
Finally,
he managed to get the tail on board,
but then the entire body of the CROC catapulted out of the water and into the
air coming down.
Besides Steve in the boat,
the man and his doc immediately jumped into the water.
Steve now grabbed what every good bronch's ropes,
mud and threw it on top of the violently thrashing crocodile.
The ideal thing here would have been to blindfold the animal,
but that was out of the question.
Steve then jumps into the boat and onto the back of the crocodile.
He threw more nursing over the beast trying to cover its eyes and then he finds
up the outboard motor and started for sure all the way back the crocodile faults
so violently that Steve was convinced the boat was going to split a pass.
Steve finally goes to the one ton crocodile secured and restraints back at his
camp is next.
Problem was how to move it.
It decided to go back to a local farm and recruit some helpers,
but when the cane farmers saw the size of angry,
they refuse to get out of their boat.
Steve had to resort to getting a front end loader to shift the CROC.
It was experiences like this that Tan Steve into a local legends,
but Steve had mixed feelings.
He felt bad to the DNC,
remove agro from his natural environment.
It's
by 1990 Steve had recaptured more than a hundred crocs.
Some of them were kept at the reptile park while the majority were released into
the wild.
In 1991 Bob and Lynn decided that Steve had come of age and was ready to take
control of the park.
Steve's goal was to make his parents proud and he knew he would do this by
turning the park,
and so one of the greatest wildlife facilities on the face of the earth is first
step was to rename the park Australia Zoo.
He then threw himself into creating the most exciting educational and
entertaining wildlife experience that zoo visitors would ever experience.
The highlights would be the crocodile show where Steve would be right up close
and personal with crocs totally in control and showing no fear.
He would tell the crowds what passionate and loving animals they work with is
huge personality,
boundless energy.
He quickly one over the public and attendance figures went through the roof
in 1991 among the tens of thousands of visitors to Australia Zoo was Terry rain.
It's a veterinarian and animal lover from the United States.
She was looking for a place to relocate cougars that had been used in the
entertainment industry.
She was drawn to their crocodile demonstration and the fast talking Aussie who
was in there with the deadly creatures,
Terri,
she wrote down her immediate impressions of Steve.
I thought there was no one like this anywhere in the world.
He sounded like an environmental Tarzan,
a larger than life superhero guy.
Steve managed to catch sight of Terry and the crowd and according to him it was
love at first sight.
The two kindred spirits were engaged for months after their first encounter.
They married in Eugene,
Oregon,
Terry's hometown on June the fourth 1992 the honeymoon was spent hunting.
Crocodiles in northern Queensland does say that Terry was out of our elements on
this trip would be an understatement.
She had never been into the Hash Australia and Alice and she definitely hadn't
been on a crocodile hunter before,
but trusting implicitly in the man that she referred to as her prince,
she threw herself into the experience,
the company,
the winds on their honeymoon adventure with Steve's friends,
John Stainton,
stains in films,
the action of the CROC hands and other adventures including Terry's first
encounter with a six foot long black snake.
This footage became the first episode of a new animal planet TV show called the
crocodile hunter.
The series which featured both Steve and Terry was so successful that a second
and then a third series were ordered.
It was a hit in over 130 countries with hundreds of millions of people embracing
Steve's lovable and over the top.
Aussie personality is trademark catch phrase,
cranky became known the world over.
Crikey Kreigan the final episodes of series three.
We're entitled at Steve's last adventure.
It followed him across the world as he embarked upon adventures everywhere from
the Himalayas to South Africa and China.
The Crocodile Hunter series allowed Steve to take his conservation message to
the world.
He viewed it as his life's mission to work tirelessly to save the world's
endangered species.
As a result of his name recognition,
he became the front man for a number of media campaigns and became the
passionate ambassador for Australia and tourism,
Steve Crusaded for wildlife preservation,
using his fame to bring the issue to the public consciousness in the late 1990s
he also discovered a new species of sea turtle and was at the forefront if a
campaign against animal poaching.
He also funds in large nature reserves,
not just in Australia but also in Fiji.
Vanuatu and the United States.
Irwin's TV series fame led some more television and even some movie work.
He appears in 2000 and one's doctor Doolittle to as himself and then started in
the crocodile hunter collision course the following year in 2006 he provided the
voice for an elephant seal named Trev in the movie happy feet.
The money that Steve made from his TV and movie appearances was poured into
building new exhibits for Australia Zoo and for funding conservation projects.
The zoo was designed as an animal park with the comfort of the animals being the
foremost concern.
Fences and cages would only be used when absolutely necessary.
The staff at the zoo grew to about 50 and the area grew to take up about a
hundred acres.
This year.
He won the award for Best Australian tourist attraction in 2003 to 2004 and 2004
the Australian animal hospital was opened right next to the zoo hospital cancer
for around 6,000 animals each year in 2006 Australia.
As you retail,
one of the Australian tourism retailing,
Steven Terry had two children together.
I've been de born in 1998 and Robert in 2003 Bindeez birth was filmed and shown
on TV for the crocodile hunter series.
Steve had been filming for the show when he got the call that Terry's waters had
broken.
He turns up at the hospital two hours later with a complete film group in tow.
Terry was surprised about sounds.
What was her nature?
She took it all in their stride.
They were both delighted when they found out they had a baby girl.
Steve knew instantly what the name was going to be.
Windy sue after his favorite CROC and his favorite dog,
Steve was the self proclaimed proudest father on the face of the earth.
He hadn't been de bonded instantly becoming virtually inseparable.
She winds on to her first wildlife documentary,
shoot it just six days old.
Then the would grow up in the international spotlight starring in our own show
Bindi jungle girl when she was eight years old.
Although the series adds the year after Steve's passing,
it was shot before he died and so he featured in several episodes.
November of 2003 found Steve Filming a documentary off the coast of Baja,
California Peninsula in Mexico about sea lions or report came through the boat's
radio that a pair of scuba divers were missing in the area.
Steve immediately shut down filming and join the search.
The next state members of his crew found one of the divers thinking to a rocky
cliff edge Stevens and other rescuer broad the man back to their boat.
The other man's body was located a short time after in early 2004 Steve made the
news for the wrong reasons when video was shown of him feeding a Checkin Caucus,
do a 12 and a half.
It's salt water crocodile while holding his one month old infant son Charles
Welfare and animal rights groups are like a,
condemns the action with some referring to it as child abuse,
but if Steven Terry contended that he had full control over the situation,
nevertheless Steve did apologize.
Doing so on the American channel,
NBC,
the incidents prompted the Queensland's government's to enact a law stating that
no one trains persons or children were allowed inside a crocodile enclosure.
Steve was also criticized for his conservation views,
which some viewed as overly simplistic and weighted towards tourism.
The Sydney Morning Herald wrote to that his message boil down to eating reason.
Crocs is bad for tourism and therefore more cruel than eating other animals.
There were,
however other industry experts who poured preys upon oh and and the work that he
had done to raise the public's awareness of conservation issues.
Mark towns ends,
the CEO of Queensland's RSBC called him a modern day Noah,
while the Canadian environmentalist remarks after Steve's passing,
that humanity will not protect that which we fear or do not understand.
Steva when helps us understand those things that many people thought were a
nuisance at best or at worst,
that's made him a great educator.
And it's conservationist Steve's zone,
conservation mentor,
what was British conservationist and a film maker.
So David Attenborough and month after Steve's death Terrio when presented
Attenborough with a lifetime achievement award and his acceptance speech.
So David praised Steve saying that he taught people how wonderful and exciting
nature was.
And he was a born communicator
throughout is 44 years.
Steve had taken on and defeated many of the most dangerous creatures on the
planet.
It was ironic then that the animal that would get the better of him was saying
normally tranquil fish.
On September the fourth 2006 he was filming off Australia's Great Barrier Reef
for a documentary to be called oceans deadliest.
The weather had been bad for several days,
so Steve had been sitting around with little to do but wait for the weather to
improve that day.
He decided to do some snorkeling in the shallow waters,
which could be films for his daughter Bindeez New TV show you've got down into
the water,
which was only at chest height.
Seeing a large blue bull sting ray,
he came over the top of it in order to film it.
As it swam away,
just as he hovered above it,
the sting ray thrust up its tail and it's began starting upwards.
A Barb was shot directly and to Steve's chest,
immediately pulled it out and rose to the top and struggled to get back into the
boat.
The crew administered CPR and then rushed him to the nearest hospital that he
was announced dead on arrival.
Steve's legacy lives on through his wife,
Terry and just children Bindi and Robert.
These three wildlife warriors continue to run Australia Zoo and to honor the
memory of this truly amazing man.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the rice
and other ways.
Thank you.